Speaker 6: Are people actually doing that?
Because from conservatives, I hear all the
time that, like, people don't want to work
and they'll just, you know, apply to a job
just to get unemployment.
And one note, that's actually a thing that
happens.
Speaker 1: So first of all, in order to initially
qualify for unemployment, you actually have
to be unemployed.
So in normal circumstances, you have to have
lost a job but not been fired for cause.
Right.
And so first, so just to qualify for unemployment,
some some barriers have to be some threshold
has to be met.
Is it as simple as applying to a few jobs
to continue receiving unemployment?
It basically is, yeah.
And it depends on the state.
Like, for example, when I was in college,
I used to work for the now defunct Circuit
City, and when they switched from commission
to hourly for salespeople, they laid off the
top salespeople, one of which I was.
And so I got to collect unemployment because
my my position was eliminated.
I had to go on and say, I'm looking for a
job.
I wasn't asked where did I apply?
It was just how have you been looking for
a job?
Yes, I have.
And then I would get the money.
That system may have changed.
The systems are different in each state.
That is something that you can do.
You apply for a few jobs and then you continue
collecting unemployment.
I am not worried about this and I've made
a couple of clips explaining why.
But fundamentally enhanced unemployment ends
in September.
You are not allowed to be on unemployment
an indefinite amount of time.
Many people, many, many people in the fall
are going to get to the end of unemployment.
And at that point, they are going to stop
receiving the benefits.
So they are either going to have to figure
out how to pay for their expenses without
making any money or they're going to have
to go and get themselves a job.
So any any social insurance program will have
some free riders or people who just do the
minimum in order to keep collecting the unemployment
as long as the system big picture is working
and unemployment and enhanced unemployment
saved so many people during the pandemic,
I don't worry about a few free riders.
They're going to lose their benefits relatively
soon anyway.
The benefits don't last forever.
Speaker 6: I think you suggest if a conservative
is saying that, like, you know, unemployment
is just keeping people lazy and keeping lost
and working, just like just like you mentioned
the benefits and say that like it's not actually,
as you know, reliable to like liberals, as
conservatives think it is.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And there is no evidence that most people
want to earn what you learn on unemployment
and don't work.
We have a really rare situation right now
because of the pandemic and the enhanced unemployment.
But generally speaking, people want to work.
Generally speaking, you make more working
than on state unemployment.
Now, we have a again, we have an enhanced
unemployment and there are some people who
would be satisfied just making unemployment
and and not working.
But it's very few many people get meaning
from work.
People get a connection to other people.
Most people want to work, period.
Speaker 6: Right.
This is actually my first time trying to call
it so it means a lot to be able to speak with
you.
So beautiful for all the content.
Speaker 1: Thanks for the call.
Appreciate it.
Thank you very much